madame monsieur bonsoir ou assis les
titres que nous allons développer dans
ce journal
l'accident de michael schumacher sur les
circuits de silverstone en
grande-bretagne un choc en pleine
vitesse le champion ait opéré pour une
fracture à la jambe près de londres
la révolte des étudiants à téhéran la
tension monte d'un cran il s'étend à
plusieurs autres villes limogeage d'un
des responsables des violences
policières après l'acte de malveillance
à la gare de lyon qui a sérieusement
perturbé le trafic tgv hier le coût du
vandalisme à la sncf à turin aujourd'hui
les cérémonies descente en de fiat
siècle d' aventure pour le groupe
autonomiste dirigée par la famille
agnelli à parcours mythique qui se
confond avec l'histoire du pays
mais avant ce journal avec cette sortie
de piste en pleine vitesse de michael
schumacher sur le circuit de silverstone
en grande-bretagne un choc à près de 200
kilomètres heure qui aurait pu avoir de
très graves conséquences
mais grâce au dispositif de sécurité mis
en place à la fois sur le circuit et sur
les voitures
le choc a été amorti michael schumacher
a été opéré pour une double fracture à
la jambe dans un hôpital britannique
christelle bertrand à 200
kilomètres/heure michael schumacher
s'est encastré dans le mur de pneus
installés devant les règles de sécurité
visiblement conscient il n'a pas pu
sortir seul de sa voiture le pilote est
resté plusieurs minutes dans ce qui
reste de la formule 1 avant d'être
évacué de la piste sur une civière
l'accident est survenu au premier tour
de la course schumacher veut doubler
leurs vannes
mais l'allemand va tout droit pour
l'instant l'écurie ferrari met en cause
les freins arrière qui n'ont pas
fonctionné normalement
de son côté et 10h vine l'autre pilote
ferrari a déclaré que la piste était
très sale à l'intérieur du virage
il critique également les bacs à sable
le fond d'une voiture est plat et
lorsqu'elle arrive tout droit lancé à
pleine vitesse élevée sur le sable au
lieu de s'arrêter
or vine a rappelé que l'association des
pilotes avaient suggéré d'installer des
bacs à sable inclinés ce comité de
vigilance a été créée après l'accident
mortel d'ayrton senna sur le circuit
d'imola en 1994
depuis les pilotes ont fait pression
pour augmenter les normes de sécurité
aujourd'hui à silverstone michael
schumacher a échappé au pire
les pneus de sécurité mais aussi la
position du pédalier placé en retrait de
l'axé des roues ont sauvé les jambes et
la vie du pilote lesquels schumacher a
été évacué en hélicoptère 45 minutes
après son accident
transféré à l'hôpital de 900 tonnes le
pilote souffre d'une double fracture
tibia-péroné à la jambe droite selon son
entourage
michael schumacher ne pourra pas quitter
l'hôpital avant le début de la semaine
et sur le circuit de silverstone cette
course a été marquée par un autre
incident le champion du monde en titre
mika hakkinen dont la voiture a perdu
une roue en plein virage
la course a été à nouveau arrêté
finalement c'est l'écossais david
coulthard sur mclaren qui a remporté la
course le tour de france également riche
en émotions lors du contre la montre
particulièrement prisé par le public
l'américain bobby unit ch a fait une
chute dans une descente
il a été évacué vers l'hôpital de metz
et c'est son compatriote lance armstrong
qui finalement remporté cette 8e étape
et récupère le maillot jaune de leader
laurent vautrot philippe des langues
contre la montre contre le public contre
la terre entière richard virenque a du
mal à se frayer un passage
victime de sa popularité le bâlois doit
réviser ses ambitions à la baisse
sur un parcours de 56 km 500 très
difficile difficile voire dangereux
abraham olano grand favori et
spécialistes et de l'exercice ne
parvient pas à redresser sa trajectoire
dans un virage serré il se relèvera
mais il a perdu l'étape ou grave encore
l'américain jim leech tombe dans une
descente il ne repartira pas giuly che
sonné selon un premier diagnostic et là
quelques côtes fracturées le tour de
france perd une de ses têtes d'affiché
mais chez cofidis
on ne veut pas polémiquer
et d'enjeux simplement levé 2 les
joueurs prennent beaucoup de risques
l'important normalement t'es toujours
deuxièmes derrière boorman
allez c'est bien ça ce contre-la-montre
nous l'avons vécu dans la voiture de
vincent lavenu le directeur sportif de
casino devant lui gilles maignan
champion de france du contre-la-montre
depuis deux ans dans la descente du
beach est tombé maignan roule à 90 km
heure il ne chute pas mais il a du mal
malgré les encouragements de 15 secondes
a finalement maignan terminera à la 19e
place à moins de cinq minutes des
premiers et le champion de france du
chronomètre ne finira pas premier
français puisqu'il sera battu par
christophe moreau études festina a
retrouvé un leader grâce à son troisième
temps aujourd'hui
morrow s'empare de la deuxième place au
général alex du le deuxième de l'étape
après un superbe parcours ne pouvait
rien contre lance amstrong déjà
irrésistible lors du prologue
l'américain a repoussé vu le à 58
secondes et olano à plus de deux minutes
il récupère le maillot jaune qu'il
espère garder jusqu'à paris
cette fois c'est clair armstrong veut
décrocher la lune
l'accueil était à l'étranger toujours
dominé par la révolte des étudiants en
iran un mouvement de protestation qui
est montée d'un cran encore aujourd'hui
20 ans après la révolution islamique de
l'ayatollah khomeini les manifestations
de ces milliers de jeunes qui pour la
quatrième journée descendre dans la rue
un mouvement qui s'étend désormais à
plusieurs grandes villes universitaires
du pays laurent doucier quatrième
journée de manifestations à téhéran
limogeage du commandant des forces de
police de la capitale et un de ses
adjoints démission refusée du ministre
de l'enseignement supérieur depuis
quelques jours et après l'annoncé
officielle de la mort d'un des
manifestants
la crise en iran est en train de devenir
politique serré d'un événement
extrêmement important qu'est ce qu'il
s'agit de la plus importante
manifestation de protestation populaire
dans ce pays depuis les premières années
de la révolution islamique en 1979
chaque jour qui passe apporte aux
étudiants plus de soutien de la part de
la population qui est très largement
acquise à leur cause
une partie importante aussi du
gouvernement le leur est acquis il ne
fait pas de mystère que le
le président khatami a beaucoup de
sympathie pour les étudiants qui le lui
rendent d'ailleurs parce qu'il est très
populaire dans les univers tutelle les
adversaires sont toujours les mêmes d'un
côté des étudiants qui demandent une
accélération des réformes sociales et
politiques
de l'autre des conservateurs religieux
majoritaire au parlement qui contrôle la
justice qui vote de nouvelles
restrictions aux libertés de la presse
et qui veulent toujours imposer la loi
islamique
ce matin vingt mille personnes
manifestaient à téhéran et d'autres
manifestations avaient lieu dans
d'autres villes du pays
en israël la rencontre attendue entre le
nouveau premier ministre ehud barak et
le président palestinien pour la
première fois et août barak s'est dit
déterminé à appliquer l'accord de wye
plantation sujet qu'il avait habilement
contourné depuis son arrivée au pouvoir
l'enjeu est d'importance pour redonner
vie au processus de paix charles
enderlin l'image que le proche orient
attendait l'avouer ce et ehud barak
accueil assez arafat du côté israélien
du barrage de jerez au nord de gaza
d'emblée les deux hommes entendent
donner l'impression de retrouvailles
chaleureuses
autre image au début de la rencontre
la poignée de main pour les photographes
yasser abed rabbo le ministre
palestinien de la culture suggère
d'ouvrir cette boîte
elle contient les cadeaux l'ancien
testament offert par ehud barak et
yasser arafat qui lui a offert un coran
sur le fond le chef du gouvernement
israélien a prononcé la petite phrase
qu'attendait le président palestinien
nous sommes engagés dit-il à appliquer
l'accord de wye plantation ainsi que
tous les accords conclus
il a ajouté nous encore donneront
l'application de façon à ce qu'elles se
combine avec les avancer vers un
règlement permanent
un point que yasser arafat a accepté au
cours de la discussion
ce qui n'a pas empêché un peu plus tard
de rappeler ses exigences ehud barak
les retraites prévu de cisjordanie
l'arrêt de la colonisation
la libération des prisonniers
palestiniens détenus en israël
mais l'autorité palestinienne est prête
à se montrer patiente a laissé au
premier ministre le temps d'organiser
ces équipes de négociateurs
une chose est sûre le processus de paix
israélo-palestinien est sortie ce soir
de l'impasse au kosovo les représentants
des serbes ont décidé de rompre leur
coopération avec la kfor et ce pour
protester contre les violences que
subissent leurs communautés
avec le retour des réfugiés albanais ce
sont des milliers de serbes qui ont pris
le chemin de l'exode ou qu'ils ont été
chassés de chez eux la stratégie de la
peur utilisé par lui ces cas pour
récupérer des quartiers entiers
autrefois habitée par des serbes
l'exemple à pristina agnès vahramian et
nathalie gallet cinquième étage bloc
numéro neuf quartiers de dardagna la
famille petrovic s'en va je suis menacé
tout les dix quinze minutes raconte le
père ils ont tué mon voisin ils l'ont
poignardé trois fois égorgé comme un
mouton
c'est une situation de fou mylan et sa
femme ont tenu 28 jours après la défaite
des troupes serbes
mais depuis ce meurtre ils ne vivent
plus c'est un cousin de serbie qui a
pris le risque de venir les chercher
dans ce semi remorque il emporte tous
les petrovic n'ont aucun espoir de
revenir c'est un autre équipé pour s'en
débarrasser qu'il confie la clé de leur
appartement dans le quartier vivait une
majorité de serbes l'administration leur
avait donné priorité aux blocs 9 37
familles serbes voisiner avec sept
albanaises seulement retour sur le
palier du cinquième étage l'appartement
où le meurtre a été commis trois jours
avant et déjà occupé par une famille
albanaise
mais on nous explique qu'en fait il n'y
a pas eu de crime que ces jeunes filles
dont la maison a été brûlé par les
serbes ont même reçu la clé de ce trois
pièces des mains du propriétaire
pourtant des traces de sang sont encore
visibles les serrures ont été forcés
changé dans la montée d'escaliers des
non albanais ont remplacé les non-serbes
là on précise que pour tout litige
les habitants du bloc peuvent prévenir
l'ofce cas c'est d'ailleurs elle qui
fait la police cet appartement vide a
été réservé personne n'ose y entrer
habitante depuis dix ans de l'immeuble
c'est albanaise explique que ses voisins
serbes doivent partir pendant les
bombardements de l'otan leur
paramilitaires tirait des coups de feu
dans l'escalier au premier étage un
voisin albanais protège dans la journée
dragan le dernier serbe de l'immeuble
dragan explique que la nuit ils poussent
cette commode contre la forte qu'il
appelle la kfor au moindre bruit
nous sommes revenus trois jours après ce
tournage au bloc numéro 9 l'appartement
des petrovic les serbes du 5e avait été
forcée ce garçon se dit membre de l'ue
checa hilare à tizi sionnel appartement
pour sa famille dont l'habitation a
brûlé au premier dragan a fait ses
valises pour le monténégro il a confié
son appartement documents à l'appui à
ses amis albanais comme au bloc numéro 9
les serbes petite famille par famille le
kosovo le multi ethnisme prônée par les
nations unies devient donc de plus en
plus une fiction retour en france avec
ce geste de malveillance qui a provoqué
hier une grande pagaille à la gare
lien en effet la chute volontaire
n'accable a entraîné de nombreux retards
sur les lignes tgv
un acte de vandalisme qui n'est pas
isolé yann fronty dudit rancoeur il aura
fallu s'armer de patience hier soir pour
partir en vacances de la gare de lyon au
total une à trois heures d'attentes pour
deux mille personnes dont certaines
restent est plutôt sereine des frais
dans ma vie c'est pas rien qui
un carton il y aura deux tournées
j'arrivais un jour plus tard ses parents
validé
à l'origine de ce gigantesque
embouteillage
un acte de malveillance c'est ce câble
lancé sur la voie à l'entrée de la gare
de lyon qui a paralysé le trafic est
immobilisé 50 tgv 20 trains grandes
lignes et de nombreux drames à
destination de la banlieue
un accident qui va coûter cher à la sncf
d'ores et déjà le remboursement des
voyageurs est estimé à un million de
francs
ça fait beaucoup de réparations à faire
sur le matériel au coût de réparations à
faire sur les installations et puis au
final c'est un peu notre image qui est
attaqué à chaque fois on doit en plus
dire que certaines malveillance porte
atteinte à la sécurité ou risque de
porter atteinte à la sécurité et par
conséquent il n'y a pas d' acte banal
dans ce domaine là un acte de
malveillance qui n'est pas isolé l'année
dernière la sncf ainsi dépensé 100
millions de francs pour la remise en
état de ces trains des gares et des
voies la sncf qui en outre a perdu 350
millions de francs à cause de la fraude
pour remédier à tous ces maux la
compagnie ferroviaire mise désormais sur
la prévention en renforçant sa présence
dans les gares et en formant son
personnel à la gestion de situations
conflictuelles
avec l'arrivée des vacanciers les
risques d' incendies notamment dans le
sud de la france
l'exemple de prévention sur l'île de
porquerolles où il est désormais
interdit de fumer en dehors des
habitations
yasmina farber frédéric besson ils sont
les anges gardiens d'un site
exceptionnel l'île de porquerolles 1200
hectares interdite aux voitures des
centaines de chemins où le fleuve peut
se déclencher
n'importe qui lille est un parti d'un
conservatoire botanique
il ya certaines espèces qu'il n'existe
qu'ici et que si on les détruit
insisteront plus donc il faut d'abord
respecter la nature et que les gens qui
viennent en vacances essaye de faire
attention non seulement aux problèmes d'
incendies dans le var mais aussi à tous
les problèmes d'environnement aux
actuellement sur cette plage des
inconscients ou par exemple organiser un
bivouac un feu à quelques mètres des
pins la patrouille équestre doit sans
cesse rappeler la réglementation aux
vacanciers
avec une nouveauté un arrêté préfectoral
interdit de fumer partout sur l'île même
sur la plage et chevaux observe les
agents conseil
posez cigarette sur les plages ou fait
c'est bien attention respecter cette
réglementation
ça gâche un petit peu les vacances bonne
journée
nous savons que c'est un problème de
d'explication c'est un problème
d'information mais aussi dans certains
cas et notamment lors des journées très
dangereuses ou vienne conjonction
d'affluence de sécheresse de la
végétation et devant aussi de
verbalisation 900 francs d'amendé le pv
peut faire réfléchir
mais devant les chevaux et les uniformes
les vacanciers sont généralement docile
la mission de prévention de la
patrouille équestre va durer tout l'été
les agents ont décidé de laisser un
espace de liberté aux fumeurs
exclusivement les pieds dans l'eau pour
mieux faire connaître cette maladie du
système nerveux la sclérose en plaques
qui touche près de 60000 personnes
l'initiative de cet équipage qui
participe au tour de france à la voile
ils ont affrété une vedette pour qu'une
dizaine de malades puissent assister à
la course benoît thevenet valérie
crétins stéphanie est atteinte de
sclérose en plaques
aujourd'hui elle est en mer avec une
dizaine d'autres malades pour suivre une
étape du tour de france à la voile et
plus particulièrement un bateau inscrit
sous le nom de déficit et rose en
plaques
une idée qu'ont eu une quinzaine
d'étudiants pour faire connaître cette
maladie nerveuse faire partager ce
plaisir à d'autres personnes des
personnes qui en ont besoin et en plus
qui ont besoin de faire connaître la
maladie
c'est une maladie qui est assez peu
connu et pour donner un peu plus de
poids à cette initiative un grand
champion a accepté de parrainer
l'équipage
sportif en général si on peut d'abord
donner de notre temps et soutenir une
cause passait bien et puis la deuxième
raison c'est que c'était cette
initiative et des prises par des
étudiants et c'est un montant un projet
d'étudiants je crois que ça c'est une
très très bonne démarche étudiante
stéphanie n'a jamais pu l'être vraiment
ces quelques jours avant ses 18 ans que
la maladie ait fait son apparition
tombé directement de mon lit donc c'est
tourner j'ai viré et je tombais sans
pouvoir me relever parce que vont donc
j'avais perdu l usage de ma jambe et un
bras et je veux dire franchement que
j'ai vécu un cauchemar un cauchemar
éveillé
imprévisible et plus ou moins
invalidantes la sclérose en plaques a
des conséquences multiples pertes de
l'equilibre tremblements paralysie
fatigue intense et ce n'est que depuis
un an grâce aux traitements qui a tenu
ces troubles les grâce à un emploi enfin
décroché que stéphanie a retrouvé le
moral avec la nouvelle situation
maintenant je suis recomposée alors
pendant des années j'étais complètement
disloqué un peu partout des fois je
savais pas qui c'était et une journée en
mer c'est aussi une façon de vivre comme
tout le monde court en fait pour moi
représentons course à la vie le but
n'est pas de gagner mais c'est
participer
et même si elle garde les séquelles des
crises antérieures
stéphanie préfère ne penser qu'à la
bonne période qu'elle vit actuellement
l'avenir est lui trop incertain pour
qu'elle est en vie de l'envisager
l'italie célèbre les 100 ans de fiat
l'occasion pour le constructeur
automobile de sortir dès demain à
nouveau modèle une nouvelle punto
aujourd'hui des festivités présidé par
le chef de l'état le président du
conseil en hommage au parcours
exemplaire de cette entreprise dont le
destin s'est confondu avec celui du pays
ne dit on pas ce qui est bon pour fiat
est bon pour l'italie l'histoire de la
dynastie agnelli notre correspondant
alain de chalvron des premières voitures
au plus belle ferrari des biplans aux
fusées des fonderies à l'ancienne au
robot c'est toute l'histoire de fiat
l'histoire d'un empire qui va bien au
delà de l'automobile l'histoire d'un
pays
l'histoire d'une dynastie elle est née
ici cette histoire rue dante à turin en
1899 est un groupe de copains rejeton de
bonne famille piémontaise décident de
fonder la fiat fabrique italienne
automobile de tueur à la fièvre toux de
chev un veto aux jeunes produisait alors
des voitures de luxe et une voiture
comme celle ci est extrêmement bien fine
bouche legrand lui destiné à une
clientèle des listes du groupe de
copains se détache très vite giovanni
agnelli un ex officier de cavalerie
industriel visionnaire et cette étoile
mais c'est sciemment pénale
il disait textuellement nous sommes à
l'aube d'une nouvelle ère
l'ère du grand capital l'ère des masses
à l'ère des grandes entreprises
industrielles où je me trouve peut-être
disait-il
mais l'automobile modifiera de fond en
comble la vie sociale du siècle à venir
mais la tchèque slovénie lusine de turin
passe de 150 ouvriers en 1900 à 40000
après la guerre de 14
agnelli s'inspire des méthodes de forbes
est créé dans les années 30 la plus
incroyable usine du monde
le lingo tôt la chaîne de montage
finissait sur le toit où les voitures
était essayé une fois terminée après le
fascisme et la seconde guerre mondiale
passée sans trop de difficulté un pied
dans chaque camp fiat se lance à corps
perdu dans ce qui va être sa spécialité
la petite voiture populaire la 500 la
600 et ses dérivés c'est l'époque du
miracle italien et il va bien falloir
que djehani le petit fils du fondateur
vie sa grande carcasse de séducteur dans
ces micro voiture son heure d'arrivée
1967 fini pour lui la dolce vita
le voilà aux commandes comme fille sous
son règne
fiat va manger toute l'industrie
automobile italienne lancia alfa romeo
ferrari maserati toutes marques
prestigieuses absorbé fiat devient le
numéro 6 mondial et pourtant
malheureusement alors à il ya un excès
de faire face étaient appliquées
il faut voir dans deux trois quatre cinq
ans ou la pollution dans ce vaudeville
où la capacité de chacun ce quelque
chose qui ne sera pas chez soi
fiat a mis tous les atouts de son côté
pour être au rendez vous du millénaire
elle fut notamment une des premières à
se globaliser mais elle a un problème il
va falloir maintenant qu'elle se marie
tout en gardant le pouvoir entre les
mains la famille la richissime libanaise
mouna ayoub qui a notamment racheté le
phocéa le bateau de bernard tapie
explose actuellement au musée de la mode
de mars et son incroyable collection de
robes de haute couture elle n'en possède
plus d'un millier et a choisi ses
modèles favoris pour les présenter au
grand public
nicolas cornu langlois et bernard connor
ont rencontré mouna yaoum à bord du
fossé
elle aurait pu rester une richissime
oisive mouna your libanaise divorcée
d'un ingénieur saoudien mère de cinq
enfants a choisi l'action et
l'indépendance
depuis deux ans il s'est consacré à la
restauration perfectionniste de ce
bateau mythique dont personne ne voulait
plus et pour lequel ces lesté d'une
poignée du bijou à marseille c'est une
auto passion qu'elle vient dépendre la
haute couture que l'on dit en perdition
l'erreur c'est mon côté féminin les
bateaux c'est mon côté machines à sous
mais je suis vraiment un mélange elle
n'a pratiquement jamais porté 620 robe
parmi le millier acheté depuis 20 ans de
peur de les animer car pour elle il
s'agit de chefs-d'oeuvre d'un art noble
voilà tous besoin d'art dans la vie
certaines personnes ne comprennent rien
au tableau comme moi même mais je me
reconnais dans une robe dans une
création d'autres choix se fait-il par
coups de foudre comme pour le fossé a
d'abord il y avait l'émotion sans doute
maintenant il ya plutôt la connaissance
de
du vêtement j'ai aussi acquis une
certaine indépendance dans mon choix
plus personne n'est plus rien ne
conditionnent on peut même distinguer à
travers cette collection des moments de
ma vie où on voyait où j'étais plus
timides moins timide plus dévoués moins
dévoués et cette robe en plumes
d'autruche et jean délavé de jean paul
gaultier
pourquoi fait-elle partie de votre
collection mais c'est mal avec cette
europe représente une joie de vivre et
une aisance si vous voulez un peu de
folie beaucoup de jeunesse et elle a
beaucoup d'humour les heelys de van gogh
brodé pour saint laurent le manteau
coromandel de chanel les folies massac
de galliano pour dior
autant de témoignages vivace de la haute
couture qu'elle défend comme une mécène
mais son vrai projet sous devenir
armateurs elle a rendez-vous à
l'america's cup en nouvelle-zélande avec
un autre bateau à restaurer
il y aura un an jour pour jour
l'équipe de france en très vivante dans
la légende en gagnant la coupe du monde
contre le brésil difficile de savoir ce
qu'il reste aujourd'hui de l'effet
mondial
en tout cas les tricolores sollicité par
de nombreuses sociétés ont su vendre et
surtout bien gérer leur image
le marketing des bleus ressemble à ça
christelle bertrand bernard connor du
monde ça vaut de l'or
les héros ont monnayé leur victoire sur
le terrain publicitaire avec plus ou
moins de réussite les joueurs
professionnels se sont transformés en
acteurs amateurs
les footballeurs sont devenus la crème
des sportifs français
chaque spot est fait sur mesure suivant
la personnalité du joueur
mais motus sur le montant des contrats
un champion du monde est aussi cher
qu'une star de cinéma entre un et deux
millions de francs plie à pipi c'est
beaucoup mais ça rapporte
en trois mois de campagne petit a fait
progresser les ventes de 20%
la victoire était en lui l'industriel a
aussi pris sa part du gâteau
alors le football at il changé son image
de marque
plus personne n'a honte de faire
soi-même de sport et ça je pense que
c'est une grande révolution qui personne
n'a honte de gagner aussi et ça c'est
une autre révolution et je pense que
c'est vraiment une excellente chose et
plus personne aussi puisqu'on revient au
football nantes de dire oui je joue au
foot et oui j'aime le foot
le 2 juillet 98 toute la france soumise
à aimer le football dans la foulée de
ses deux buts marqués en finale
zinedine zidane a vendu son image de
vainqueur il s'est à la fois payé le
luxe de poser pour une marque de
prestige et une chaîne de supermarchés
contrastées diversité faire ses courses
et sentir bon c'est possible chez les
hommes comme les femmes
zidane fait l'unanimité ce prix de
campagne ne vise pas la même clientèle
entre le parfum est le cas dit il n'y a
pas concurrence il fasse d'autres choses
très bien mais quand on demande aux gens
qui est zidane ils vous disent c'est un
footballeur ils vous disent pas c'est
l'homme de la publicité
tel ou tel autre marque donc ça n'a que
peu d'impact aujourd'hui la pub aiment
le foot industriel annonceurs
publicitaires et joueurs tout le monde a
vite réagi pour profiter de la victoire
à ce petit jeu l'équipementier a été le
plus rapide moins de cinq minutes après
le coup de sifflet final
les vainqueurs ont porté son slogan dans
la pub aussi on sait aller droit au but
par aux influences record sur les quais
pour admirer l'armada du siècle un
million de visiteurs du temps se sont
pressées aujourd'hui autour de ces
magnifiques bateaux et malgré une
chaleur caniculaire et services de
secours en pratique et plus de 600
interventions sans gravité mais les
autorités locales renouvellent leurs
conseils de prudence pour que la foule
se protègent du soleil et s'hydratent le
plus souvent possible
voilà qui nous amène à cette
extraordinaire projet construire à
l'identique une frégate qui a conduit la
fayette en amérique l'hermione est un
trois mâts qui est en train de prendre
corps à rochefort dans cette ville créée
par louis xiv pour y construire des
navires de guerre
thierry curtet à la location toutes les
prévisions enfoncé cent mille l'année
dernière deux cent mille spectateurs
cette année le chantier de la frégate
hermione devient un véritable pôle
touristique
l'armateur qu'est la ville de rochefort
ne s'attendait pas à un tel succès
devant ses yeux étonnés par ce tour de
magie les charpentier recréée à
l'identique ce bâtiment construit ici
même il y a deux cent dix ans un navire
historique
il a conduit le marquis de la fayette à
boston sa magnifique c'est une
entreprise de première qualité ou des
gens qu'est-ce qu'il impressionne le
plus quand vous arrivez ici c'est le
compteur ne grandit personne et c'est
seulement une frégate re la manette et
l'étonnement du public ne se tarit pas
combien d'arbres 2000 chaîne quelle
dimension 65 m de long 54,2 quel poids
1200 tonnes combien de temps pour la
construction 10 ans contre 11 mois en
1780 mais alors 300 ouvriers autant de
bagnards vrai au xviiie siècle cet
engouement je pense qu'il ya à peu près
ont fait rêver l'hermione quand vous
rentrez vous avez un choc c'est quand
même une pièce extrêmement rare et je
crois que là le chantier lui-même génère
de l'étonnement
parce que c'est bon ça sent bon ce
chantier est aussi une aventure
historique car de l'époque qu'il ne
reste plus aucun plan juste ses six
feuillets de relever uniquement des
chiffres
cette maquette à un en avant sur le
chantier elle permet de corriger les
hypothèses des historiens qui
multiplient et croiser leurs sources
d'information par exemple dans le
journal de bord moi ce qui m'intéresse
comme je les lui ce qui m'intéressait le
plus c'est l'analyse moquant non pas la
navigation non pas les combats mais les
rapports après combat parce tu as une
manoeuvre a été cassée sur le gâteau
pendant combat c'est qu'elle existait
donc il faudra qu'on les remette même si
elle paraît anormal pour l'époque que
pour ce type de bâtiment
on sait donc que l'hermione ressembler à
cette maquette ce sera ainsi durant les
dix années du chantier
en attendant on l'espère vers 2007
pouvoir traverser l'atlantique
comme il ya deux cents ans
le match à jules verne d'une petite
commune de gironde qui a organisé
jusqu'au 14 juillet un festival
entièrement consacré à celui qui a fait
rêver tant de générations la poésie
l'imaginaire au programme de ces
animations sur terre et dans les airs
éric perrin très gros chèque
difficile d'imaginer mieux qu'une
montgolfière pour embarquer à la
rencontre de jules verne le plus grand
romancier d'anticipation du 19e siècle
baptêmes de l'air en guise de mise en
bouche pour ce festival organisé par
créon dans le cadre de l'été girondins
20 milieu en entre deux mers
la preuve que les voyages sont toujours
extraordinaire source de rencontres pour
te que le hasard du vent vous pose en
plein jardin à l'heure du petit déjeuner
débats théâtre cinéma expositions durant
quatre jours le coeur de cette bastide
du 12e siècle ne bat que pour celui qui
reste encore aujourd'hui un auteur
d'anticipation à part et beaucoup de
visionnaire aujourd'hui il y en a peu
qui le soin au sens de l'univers et des
visionnaires qui sont plutôt dans la
dénégation du réel
j'imagine des choses autrement qu'est-ce
qu'elles sont dans la réalité que chez
julien il me semble très plutôt l'idée
de prolonger le réel sans démentir
d'étaler un peu plus voire de fêtes
jules verne n'a jamais inventé de
technologie de machines mais il a
toujours su les projeter ce qui
intéresse jules verne
ce n'est pas de reprendre tel quel ses
inventions pour en faire de la science
fiction au sens aujourd'hui je dirais
américain du terme c'est de poser la
place de l'évolution des deux des gens
de l'individu de la personne humaine
dans ce contexte d'évolution société à
partir de l'élection des techniques en
route pour l'événement de ce festival un
voyage extraordinaire très librement
inspiré du roman de la terre à la lune
durant plusieurs mois 400 bénévoles du
quartier berlioz de cours ont travaillé
avec des comédiens professionnels pour
créer ce spectacle associant théâtre de
rue musique et danse
un voyage socioculturel au centre de
l'humain
autre époque qui reparle beaucoup
d'intolérance effectivement le voyage
humain la rencontre c'est quelque chose
qui nous ouvre des hypothèses d'
aventure plutôt passionnante qui sait
ramon le funambule est peut-être le
descendants spirituels de jules verne
l'un comme l'autre font à leur façon
rêver avec la réalité
voyager avec l'imaginaire
je vous propose maintenant de suivre le
parcours de ces jeunes femmes qui se
produisent tous les soirs au festival
d'avignon
elles ont du talent elle chante dans une
vingtaine de langues leur groupe
s'appelle évasion elles sont généreuses
ouverte vers les autres elles n'ont pas
oublié qu'elles ont grandi dans des
quartiers difficiles et c'est là
qu'elles ont envie de communiquer leurs
patients jean michel carpentier abdel
juillet
elles sont six elles sont vifs et elles
ont appris à chanter ensemble depuis
l'âge de 12 ans elles ont appris à
chanter dans leur cité dans la drôme le
quartier de la monnaie
un roman
dit française et pour chacune ses
racines bretonnes algérienne
portugaise italienne
et
notre objectif il n'était pas là est
vraiment pas de lettres connues nous
départ les liens s'étaient se retrouver
tous les maires sa vie devant un micro
s'éclater faire autre chose que c'est à
loisir quoi si c'est vrai qu'il faut
cinq sens à force on s'est pris au jeu
et au celi pour enfin comme juin je vois
la vie que con certains certaines
personnes il a je dis je vais j'ai quand
même une chance d en être arrivé à un
simple elles n'oublient pas leur
histoire et reviennent donné ce qu'elles
ont reçu des cours de chant aux jeunes
des quartiers de valence et roman danois
ensuite y'a la croche qui font un de mes
temps c'est toujours la moitié la moitié
la moitié ont la double franchement il a
donné des concerts un grand mot puisque
moi je suis ça surtout pour je fais ça
en fait pour les aider à avoir une
certaine technique pour six en fonction
des buts en équipe et je leur dis
toujours mais rêvez pas c'est pas
fatiguant mais pas chanteurs comme ça
toujours la même mais en fait c'est
surtout mes bouts d'choux passé pamela
elle chante le monde amoureuse des
peuples les peuples d'amendis stèle
rien
ce fan ce journal je vous remercie de
votre attention voici les principaux
titres que nous avons développée dans
cette édition l'accident de michael
schumacher sur le circuit de silverstone
en grande-bretagne un choc en pleine
vitesse le champion été opéré pour une
fracture à la jambe
près de londres
la révolte des étudiants à teyran la
tension monte d'un cran et s'attend à
plusieurs autres villes le limogeage des
responsables des violences policières
dans un instant la météo nathalie
rihouet à 20h50 votre film les palmes de
monsieur schultz avec isabelle huppert
équipe loire et le dernier journal
florence duprat aux alentours de 00h20
demain dans les 4 vérités à 7h50
françoise laborde reçoit pascal boniface
directeur de l'institut de relations
internationales et stratégiques à 20h
vous retrouverez claude sérillon je vous
souhaite une excellente fin de soirée
sur france 2